[Music]
Rudy is with us in El Paso Texas hi Rudy
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
how you done better than I deserve
what's up yes sir I was calling because
I'd like to see if I can get some advice
for you my wife and I recently paid our
our house off good and I mean we kind of
started listening to your show but we
know we will do it too late to follow
your steps but anyway those are too late
to follow my steps well I'm just saying
you know before you ask the work why
don't you follow the baby step is baby
nozzle and you mean you had already done
some stuff out of order before you start
listening I guess you're saying okay how
can I help today though well hi my wife
and I paid off you know the house and we
made a mistake of actually buying a
truck and we have to credit card that we
have debt on my question to you was do
you think it's a good idea to take a
equity loan and pay off the remainder of
those accounts no no how would you you
got your house paid for we're never
going back dude we might sell the truck
but we're not gonna borrow on the house
so what and what do you owe on the truck
that's what my wife told me to sell the
truck on the truck I owe I'm under on
the truck I only on the truck 38 35,000
okay and what's the truck worth the
truck is probably worth at the local
place here maybe 20 something thousand
okay so you're somewhere around maybe
five or ten grand upside down give or
take more tip more like can you sir
looks at and what's your household
income my wife in between her and I we
make around fifteen thousand okay you
got a pretty expensive truck and how
much you owe on the credit cards
the card is around 15 and mine is around
16 okay so we have 31 because we are
married $31,000 in credit card debt and
$38 yeah so it takes it takes 80 grand
for y'all to be debt-free no 70 grand
for y'all to be debt free see you sir
okay and you make 115 so you could do
that in probably two years okay you
think it's just good to pay off $3,000 a
month I would either sell the truck or I
would commit to a $3,000 a month debt
reduction plan for two years okay okay
and that means you're gonna be on beans
and rice rice and beans you're gonna no
life no vacation no eating out no nothin
all we're doing is getting a stupid
truck paid off and then we keep it okay
if you want to keep it that's how you do
it if you want to make this go a whole
lot faster you can do it all in about
one year if you sold the truck and move
down in truck but don't sell the truck
to a dealer man I mean put it on private
sale you go go to Kelly Blue Book
kbb.com look at private sale what the
truck is worth if you put it on
Craigslist and you know if the dealer
tells you it's worth 25 that's what it's
worth to a dealer because they got a
resale make a profit that means you
probably can actually sell it for 30
which would leave you more like eight or
you know say 35 or 30 yeah you didn't
know what your balance was so find out
what your balance is find out what the
trucks worth and then the two of you sit
down together and go okay we're gonna
take two years to clean up this mess
we're gonna take one year and sell the
truck and then we're clean up the mess
about 3000 bucks a month though we're
going to commit to debt reduction give
or take and we're gonna knock this out
really really fast either way it's okay
with me but no I would not borrow on
your house sell the truck a long time
before I borrowed on your house to get
out of debt oh and by the way when you
sit down tonight to do all this stuff
cut up all those grata carts at Rudy's
house tonight there's gonna be a
ceremony plastic surgery ceremony like
candles get a big old pair of scissors
chop those bad boys up because they've
been such a blessing
I mean they've changed your life in
negative ways so why keep them around I
mean it's like keeping termites in the
house what
we want them we don't want them keeping
roaches in the house we don't want them
no no and that's because that's what
these things are they will eat you alive
they have because you got sloppy
thirty-one thousand dollars worth of
sloppy with those stupid things chop up
the credit cards make the decision to
keep the truck or sell the truck I don't
care but you're on a tight budget jump
on every dollar get your budget done
tighten it down you can do this Rudy you
can do it if you need more help as
you're going through it you call me back
appreciate you listening